perché sanitas ingrosso avevamo capito
challenge e cioè dovremo fare una flight
challenge però utilizzando solo cose
glitterate è imbattuto bruni ma sul
tavolo è tutto pieno di anche
l'editoriale 23303 forse non possiamo
sceglierli noi perché li sceglierò la
ruota e niente ma perché non c'è scritto
niente alla sua ruota è perché noi ci ne
vengo la quota è nervosa sceglierà il
colore rosa c'è il colore noi potremo
scegliere quello che vogliamo tra il
colore alla fine vincerà chi parolo slam
kim clijster ato di tutti come sempre
dovrete votare nel sondaggio qua chi
vince questa volta vince un premio top
rosa ho visto ma che cosa premio che
dice sono i nuovissimi clip
penso che dietro sono tantissimi e sono
nuovi e ancora più bel ricordo e muore i
cristiani del gatto reso più lunga
il primo a cosa servono i clip phone
se vi ricordate vennero già parlato
l'anno scorso proprio sedizione nuova e
ancora più bella praticamente si
attaccano dietro al telefono e
mettendoli dietro al telefono potete
tenere meglio il telefono non rischia di
cadere vi potete fare i tic toc molto
molto meglio
insomma sono fantastici io non riesco a
vivere senza infatti non l'ho mai tolto
quello dell'anno scorso ora ho messo
questo rosati sterrato che ha odore si
abbina anche alle mie unghie abbiamo i
glitter style che sono appunto
glitterati vedete che sono anche molto
stessi ei grossi sono fantastici
poi abbiamo i grammy style dove trovate
anche due o di corni le zampette del
gatto un fiorellino un teschio insomma
sono fantastici diano curati in ogni
dettaglio
questi sono i grossi style e vedete che
ci sono varie frasi in ognuno sono super
simpatici e poi black style che sono
quelli tutti neri con i disegni in più
potete semplicemente xvi tarli se volete
cambiare il disegno ogni volta e
attaccare l'altro se volete tipo
abbinarlo al vostro outfit se volete
cambiare colore volete avvolgere le
cuffie potete addirittura metterle 2 ed
ha ancora più stabilità al telefono non
potete anche usarlo come stand per il
telefono per guardare i video insomma
per quadrare i miei video su youtube
ovviamente sono quindi fantastici chi
vincerà queste challenge vincerà tutti
li trovate in edicola al 3 ore e 50 in
allegato al magazine
fatemi sapere nei commenti qual è il
vostro preferito che è il primo round
dove spero proprio di sì a questa la
giusta schiatta orengo vichi e fondiamo
un giro io spero che vi capiti il verde
severo bt il viola rosso di furgoni
ma allora se lo scelgo questo che sono
dei pigmenti glitterati rock è brutto
non era bellissimo trasformerà il mio
slime in un bellissimo colorata tirare
glitter super sberluccicanti rosse rossi
si metteranno tutta
ecco qua i miei pigmenti rossi
qua i glitter ci sono ma sono
piccolissimi per quello che danno questo
effetto visto così sembra pure bello ma
adesso che l'ho tiritera broadcaster
brutto anche noi con la gomma
trasparente invece essere fantastico
sport ma guardo un po marroncino
effettivamente un rossiccio marroncino
diciamo che lo sporco da grande insomma
vedrai che diventerà un bellissimo gala
coutinho guarda però metallizzato
[Applauso]
per il più bel moretto by invece ho
guardato visto in glitter quanto sono
piccoli tutti pontino donne buche belli
noi abbiamo sostenuto sealine rosso
aspetta abbiamo appena iniziato a girare
vorresti che si se tu l'hai non lo
vorrei blu celestino chiaro verde
pallido rilette rossi a tutto assieme
sì tutto sebbene abbastanza che
interesso mi piace anche andar a un
dottore e vediamo come uscire la
leggerezza
io lo so io lo so pepper a 9
allora se li così clipper lublu così
magari lo faccio ancora più galaxy tocca
mai
vogliamo fare voglio portare senato si è
bloccato quindi deve ritirarsi
allora io scelgo questi kit la loro
super preparato
bravissimo andiamo metterli nel play
prevediamo finora qual è più disperato e
meglio più glitterato ecco poi il ter
blues per tutte le ramblas galaxy
glitter di questi colori fantastico
sembra marte con un po d'acqua
abbiamo un po il tuo come diventa adesso
sembra un po verdolino questo è già
infatti come mai non lo voglio celeste
bardolino ecco perché lei serie si scusa
perché revel che sembra cielo stellato
altra bomba in un attimo mi ha coperto
il cielo stellato altro conto è perfetto
anche un boom ore lo sballo
adesso troppi ritardarli ok toh che ho
messo in forte contenta di come stanno
uscendo finora sono bellissimi tutte e
due di allora ma sono i tanti dovuto
scegliere uno due tre quattro letti
proprio ore 16 letta è un bellissimo
quello di l'apparente rabbia galletti
beh allora dài questa volta ho capito
vuole scegliere era proprio un pigmento
slitterà come diventerà in mezzo a quei
colori strumento di tutela
lo scopriremo ecco qua la mia bellissima
con la great herat a muro come razzi
bene e piena di glitter e paillettes e
tutto
adesso si resterebbe lei mancherà più
glitterato vendemmia un po
beh ma è scomparsa dove è finita è
finita in fondo in fondo ma è bellissimo
un bellissimo pianeta non sono proprio
curioso di vedere come diventa il tuo
con quel celeste finora il tuo non ha un
bellissimo colore aspetta o devo ancora
tutto da questo che società diventerà
stupendo qualche colore bellissimo ma
non c'entra molto questo colore piccolo
e bellissimo lo ha mischiato con questo
non significa io intelligente ripreso
con berlino infatti sta carlo besta che
non si vede come era un bell'effetto
effettivamente è diventato bertolino
celeste verdolino vabbé tutti hai visto
che freddo bello bellissimo che e per
ultimo turno attente le stiamo
avvicinando alla fine tocca a me cioè
rosmini comitato il verde che è molto
molto strano allora è lui che mi sento
questa bottiglietta di peter per tutto
rossonero ma che ti vedranno vedrai
vedrai rosso pure i criteri di superbar
gigantesco prima che si sono chiari
ok andiamo lì il nostro ok mette i miei
glitter rossi tutto inizia lo guarda
vediamo ora di mischia mischia
secondo me io sono in vantaggio guerra
come mi piace tantissimo è proprio un
galaxy fantastiche brutto e niente moto
di 30 almeno il rosso forse lo renderà
un pochino più carino mettiamo un colpo
di rosso ok pippo però non mi piace
proprio questo colore mesi invece guarda
e questo galaxy petrolio tornato con m
avrete lo faccio tutto vero che non
ricapiti beppe come l'ultimo turno
vediamo noi è bloccato
[Musica]
inter a tutti perché non ricetta
proveniamo all'età restiga di questo
biennio big vento preferito la
forteresse anche a stampare quello stato
di 36 perché perché io sono bravissimi
strachan diventi più bello del mio ex
club come l'inter è vero che bella teen
ager o ancora più ditte razionale di
attivarlo vedere con vino rosso
assessore vediamo un po teresa
migliorare il tuo con questo pigmento
marche praticamente di solo migliora o
lo distruggo che bello questo mio
abbigliamento preferito lo ha detto in
un pc mentre preferita ma arriva
un'altra volta più che mette una ferita
ma allora stai rischiando per il celeste
e allora io lefort penso che il verde lo
sta risucchiando salvarlo
ora come faremo a scegliere un vincitore
che bello mi piaceva solo quanto tutti i
preti galaxy con tasti
d'altronde io sono dell'esperto di
galaxy s o street è rivolto il movimento
di attivarli entriamo finalmente vedere
qual è il più bello e più brillante io
il più bley però frutto choudry cook
live view slime abbiamo lasciato questa
questo spiraglio di sole così riuscito a
vedere ancora meglio i glitter
guardate conto brin alla fine il colore
è uscita una sorta di rossi
guardate quanti glitter ricordate conto
e diritte rosa mi piace tantissimo mi
ricorda un galaxy un po più bizze rato
sentiamo i suoni
[Musica]
adesso è il mio twitter
vediamo ora quelle digitale se è più
chitarroso del mignone è uscita una
sorta di arge ho già detto è stupendo a
me sembra gente non è vero
pur con tetto anche bellissimo steve
jobs portata di tutti questi glitter e
sentiamo adesso le bolle ma io non sono
tantissimi ma metto in bra argento non
ho reagito il viola è perché c'è una
luglio adesso che correva contro vero
viola di rigetto di rigettare all
housing però c'è e un po metallizzato
vediamoli ora una fiaccolata è così più
bello del tuo è normale hero per aver
affatto pochi qual è il più glitterato
topico del più glitterato e mi sono il
tuo
più metallizzato il mio è più glitter
pure voi chi vincerà
siccome la challenger a per quanto lei
lo slime fiumi letterato secondo me
vinci tu perché ci sono più glitter
allora prende clip bellissimi fantastici
kit sono tutti ieri posso cambiare una
zona uefa
no mai non ti regalo ti regalo questo
risate grazie armi che privata
avrò le prove invece scaviamo per
cambiarsi nei conventi qual è il vostro
fiction preferito se volete montati
neanche la vostra foto del vostro kit
form su instagram ai nostri preferiti
sono il cuoricino glitterato per questo
qui per me che dice e sta intorno
mi ricordo di andare a correre poi la
zampina del gattino rosa rigoglioso
bosco mattina gatti non era più stato
tutto visto ski man galaxy con le
stelline tutto rosso con la scritta
negativa e l'unicorno sempre in 3d un po
più piccolino viola e gold sterrato
cabello isca brevi commenti fossi
preferiti lasciate un bel vps questo
video e ora vi lasciamo qua quattro
fratellini e sub e cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
preferita e buona visione